NICK: Hi, everyone, and welcome
again to the San
Francisco office, to another
Talks at Google event.
We're very pleased to welcome
George Packer here today to
talk about his new book, "The
Unwinding." And George is
currently a staff writer and has
been for "The New Yorker"
since 2003.
He's covered the Iraq War for
the magazine and has also
written about the atrocities
committed in Sierra Leone,
civil unrest in the Ivory Coast,
the mega city of Lagos,
and global counter insurgency.
His book "The Assassins' Gate:
America in Iraq" was named one
of the 10 best books of 2005
by "The New York Times" and
won the New York Public
Library's Helen Bernstein Book
Award and an Overseas Press
Club Book Award.
He's authored several nonfiction
books and two
novels, contributed numerous
articles, essays, and reviews
on foreign affairs, American
politics, and literature to
"The New York Times Magazine,"
"Dissent," "Mother Jones,"
"Harper's," and another
publications.
He's taught writing at Harvard,
Bennington, and Columbia.
And he currently lives in
Brooklyn, in New York.
But this is a homecoming
of sorts, because he
grew up in Palo Alto.
So welcome back to
the left coast.
Please welcome George
Packer to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
GEORGE PACKER: Thank
you, Nick.
It is wonderful to
be at Google.
There was no Google when
I was growing up here.
Google has changed everything.
And it's great always
to come back and see
what's happening here.
It always feels like if I get
depressed in other parts of
the country, to come back to
the Bay Area and sit out on
the Bay with my macchiato, ,
nothing could possibly be
wrong anywhere in the world.
And this is where you
live and work.
So lucky, you.
I'm going to talk a bit about
"The Unwinding: An Inner
History of the New America,"
and read a bit from it.
And then I'd love to answer
questions about it.
But the book began, in a way,
back in Iraq, which I covered
for "The New Yorker." And as
Iraq imploded in the early
years of the war, I went from
seeing it as a failure of
leadership--
we know their names, people
in Washington, generals,
politicians, people
in the media--
to seeing it more as an
institutional failure, as well.
You couldn't just pin it
on this or that person.
It seemed like whole American
institutions were put to this
stress test in Iraq, like we
tried to do something really
hard, harder than we'd done in
a very long time, and it
turned out the body politic was
in really bad shape from
government to media, the
military intelligence.
And I began to wonder,
how did this happen?
Has it been happening
for a long time?
Why has it happened that we were
able to rebuild postwar
Europe and we weren't able to
bring electricity to Baghdad
to the level it had been
at before the war?
And then I came home from Iraq
and covered the 2008
presidential election, and
suddenly institutions were
collapsing all around us.
Wall Street was collapsing.
General Motors.
It seemed as if all the pillars
of American life, one
after another, were eroding or
absolutely falling to pieces.
And that was the beginning
of my thinking about "The
Unwinding." I decided that I
wanted to tell the story of
how and why this happened, but
not to do it in the usual way.
There'd been lots and lots of
great books written about the
decline of the middle class in
the last generation, income
inequality, political
polarization, globalization
and its effect on the economy.
I didn't want to write
a policy book.
I wanted to write a narrative,
a book that would feel like
reading a novel, except that all
of it would be true, or as
true as I could make it.
And it would tell the story
of the past generation.
Because my view is that since
around the late '70s, which
happens to be when I graduated
from high school and Palo Alto
for good-- so everything
has gone to hell
since I left Palo Alto--
there's been a kind of undoing
of the deal that used to exist
between Americans, which was
if you did your part and
worked hard and held up your
end, there would be a place
for you in American life
and an even better
place for your children.
It was the dream of upward
mobility and equal
opportunity.
And although that dream was
never true for all Americans,
the circle of inclusion widened
to include more and
more of us.
And the reality of equal
opportunity was paid
off, was made good.
And I think in the last
generation, we've seen that
begin to come apart.
And instead there's a sense in
which rather than institutions
like the ones I named earlier
supporting the aspirations of
ordinary Americans, more and
more people feel like they're
in it on their own and have
to find their own way.
It's an age of entrepreneurs
rather than of structures and
institutions.
For some people, that's
been very good.
And for other people, that's
been destabilizing and even
devastating.
So to tell this story in this
novelistic way, I wanted to
write about the whole
country in a way.
It was a preposterous
ambition.
I think I've reached the point
in my career where I just got
tired of doing things in sort
of the way that would be
easiest for me or most
successful or following in a
template that had
worked before.
I wanted to try something
completely new in my own work.
And this book is a departure
from everything
I've written before.
I wanted to tell the story of
the most successful and the
least, the power centers like
Washington, Wall Street,
Silicon Valley, and
also the forgotten
places of the country.
The celebrities, and they're
portraits of everyone from
Jay-Z and Newt Gingrich to Alice
waters and Elizabeth
Warren in the book.
And also obscure people whom
you've never heard of, and who
are the main characters
in the book.
There's about four
or five of them.
And so this was this big
panoramic and yet very
intimate picture of the country
as it's evolved in the
last generation.
So first I'm going to read the
prologue, which will give you
a sense of the ambitions of the
book and the themes of the
book, and then talk a little
bit more about some of the
characters in it.
No one can say when the
unwinding began, when the coil
that held Americans together
in its secure and sometimes
stifling grip first gave way.
Like any great change, the
unwinding began at countless
times, in countless ways, and at
some moment, the country--
always the same country--
crossed a line of history
and became
irretrievably different.
If you were born around 1960 or
afterward, you spent your
adult life in the vertigo
of that unwinding.
You watched structures that have
been in place before your
birth collapse like pillars of
salt across the vast visible
landscape--
the farms of the Carolina
Piedmont, the factories of the
Mahoning Valley, Florida
subdivisions, California schools.
And other things harder to
see but no less vital in
supporting the order of everyday
life changed beyond
recognition--
ways and means in Washington
caucus rooms, taboos on New
York trading desks, manners
and morals everywhere.
When the norms that made the old
institutions useful began
to unwind and the leaders
abandoned their posts, the
Roosevelt republic that had
reined for almost half a
century came undone.
The void was filled by the
default force in American
life-- organized money.
The unwinding is nothing new.
There have been unwindings every
generation or two, the
fall to earth of the Founders'
Heavenly Republic in a noisy
marketplace of quarrelsome
factions, the war that tore
the United States apart and
turned them from plural to
singular, the crash that laid
waste to the business of
America, making way
for a democracy of
bureaucrats and everymen.
Each decline brought renewal.
Each implosion released
energy.
Out of each unwinding
came a new cohesion.
The unwinding brings freedom
more than the world has ever
granted and to more kinds of
people than ever before.
Freedom to go away, freedom to
return, freedom to change your
story, get your facts, get
hired, get fired, get high,
marry, divorce, go broke, begin
again, start a business,
have it both ways, take it to
the limit, walk away from the
ruins, succeed beyond your
dreams and boast about it,
fail abjectly and try again.
And with freedom, the
unwinding brings its
illusions, for all these
pursuits are as fragile as
thought balloons popping
against circumstances.
Winning and losing are
All-American games.
And in the unwinding, winners
win bigger than ever, floating
away like bloated dirigibles.
And losers have a long way to
fall before they hit bottom,
and sometimes they never do.
This much freedom leaves
you on your own.
More Americans than ever before
live alone, but even a
family can exist in isolation,
just managing to survive in
the shadow of a huge military
base without a
soul to lend a hand.
A shiny new community can spring
up overnight miles from
anywhere, then fade
away just as fast.
And old city can lose its
industrial foundation and 2/3
of its people while all
its mainstays--
churches, government,
businesses, charities, unions--
fall like building flats
in a strong wind
hardly making a sound.
Alone on a landscape without
solid structures, Americans
have to improvise their own
destinies, plot their own
stories of success
and salvation.
A North Carolina boy clutching
a Bible in the sunlight grows
up to receive a new vision of
how the countryside could be
resurrected.
A young man goes to Washington
and spends the rest of his
career trying to recall the idea
that drew him there in
the first place.
An Ohio girl has to hold her
life together as everything
around her falls apart until
in middle age she finally
seizes the chance to do more
than just survive.
As these obscure Americans
find their way in the
unwinding, they pass alongside
new monuments where the old
institutions one stood, the
outsized lives of their most
famous countryman, celebrities
who only grow more exalted as
other things recede.
These icons sometimes occupy
the personal place of
household gods.
And they offer themselves as
answers to the riddle of how
to live a good or better life.
In the unwinding, everything
changes and nothing lasts
except for the voices--
American voices--
open sentimental, angry, matter
of fact, inflected with
borrowed ideas, God, TV, and
the dimly remembered past,
telling a joke above the noise
of the assembly line,
complaining behind window
shades drawn against the
world, thundering justice to
a crowded park or an empty
chamber, closing a deal on the
phone, dreaming aloud late at
night on a front
porch as trucks
rush by in the darkness.
That just gave you a map
of the entire book.
That Ohio girl who grows up to
be an assembly line worker is
a woman named Tammy Thomas, a
black woman in Youngstown,
Ohio, who grew up while
Youngstown, this great old
steel city, lost its
mills, lost its
jobs, lost itself really.
And, yet, she somehow raised
three kids on their own
because you had one of the last
good blue collar jobs
until it was off-shored in a
bankruptcy that managed to gut
the company while making a
few people very wealthy.
And she remade herself into a
community organizer just in
time for Obama's election.
Jeff Connaughton is this
Washington operative in the
book who starts out as a Biden
guy, becomes disillusioned
with Biden, becomes a
lobbyist, becomes
disillusioned with lobbying,
and then goes back into
government to try to make Wall
Street pay for the financial
crisis, and doesn't
quite succeed.
Dean Price is the North Carolina
boy who grows up in
the Bible Belt.
His father is a
fire-and-brimstone preacher.
It is as red as a red America
gets anywhere.
He wants to be an
entrepreneur.
And so he opens a chain of truck
stops along Route 220
between North Carolina
and Virginia--
fast food, convenience
stores--
and finds that it's harder and
harder to make it as the big
box stores move in and squeeze
out local businesses, and
multinational oil companies
and national gas chains
undercut his price.
And so Dean is really
one of the main
characters in the book.
You follow these stories in the
book through the course of
this generation from the late
'70s to the present.
You move back and forth between
these main characters.
And I should also mention
someone relevant here, Peter
Thiel, who is sort of our guide
to Silicon Valley in the
book and who was obviously the
founder of PayPal and the
first outside investor
and Facebook and
noted contrarian thinker.
Tampa is a big part of the book,
so the dream of a house
in the exurbs which turned
into a nightmare when the
housing market collapsed.
You follow all their stories
over the course of these three
decades while taking little
detours into the lives of the
celebrities who were sort of
shaping the culture that these
ordinary people were growing up
in and living in and trying
to make their way in.
Dean Price ended up feeling that
he could not make it as
an independent truck
stop operator and
had a kind of epiphany.
His whole life was like a series
of epiphanies, very
religious in a somewhat
unorthodox way.
His life was a quest.
It is a quest.
And the turning point came
when he realized that the
answer to the problems
in his area.
Because his area was tobacco
country, textile country.
It had mainstays.
And they went away one by one
in the '90s and early 2000s
leaving behind a kind of
despoiled landscape.
And all the problems of the
inner city transferred to
rural America--
multiple generations on public
assistance, drug abuse,
unemployment, out-of-wedlock
birth.
Dean decided that the answer to
the decline in his corner
of America was alternative
energy.
And he became a kind of Johnny
Appleseed for biodiesel, first
trying out canola seeds as the
source and finally turning to
waste oil from the many barbecue
restaurants and other
sources of oil in
North Carolina.
So I'm just going to finish by
reading one passage that
catches Dean Price just as he's
making this conversion
from being a failed truck stop
entrepreneur to a local
prophet of biodiesel.
A two-lane asphalt road ran
past the woods, white oak,
shag bark hickory,
Carolina ash.
And in the shadows of the trees,
a tobacco barn was year
by year collapsing on itself,
the metal roof sloping inward,
pieces of bare siding hanging
loose from nails.
Nearby, a white clapboard
house with empty windows
squatted at the roadside
half-smothered in tree
branches and vines while a
fire-scorched handwritten sign
on the outside wall still
advertised Crush.
Farther along, the road took a
turn, and a tidy brick ranch
house with a big satellite dish
mounted on top stood in
the golden sunlight of
a red-brown field.
Another bend, a gentle hill,
deep woods again, then an
abandoned metal warehouse
alone in a clearing.
The road straightened and
flattened and came to a
stoplight where a pair of strip
malls faced each other,
parking lots full.
A Walgreen's across from a
McDonald's, shell opposing BP.
Another light.
A shuttered car dealership.
A vast scrapyard with a mountain
of twisted metal and
stacked timbers next door to a
spinning mill that was being
methodically gutted like a great
whale and sold off one
part of the time.
Then downtown, the lonely
little Main Street, a
taekwondo studio, a government
benefits office, a closed
restaurant, a nameless corner
store for rent, two
pedestrians in four blocks, a
Dollar General that marked the
far end of town.
On the other side, the country
opened up at once, the road
passing fields, corn planted on
one, nothing on the next.
Weeds and clods of dirt.
Then a residential development
with two-story look-alike
houses in neat rows laid out
across someone's former
tobacco farm.
And beyond the subdivision,
isolated on acres of grass
behind a split-rail fence
and a man-made lake, the
super-sized faux chateau of
a celebrity NASCAR driver.
The landscape Dean had returned
to, where he planned
to live out his life, was very
old and also new, as
particular as anything in
America, and also as generic,
as beautiful and as ugly.
In his imagination, it had
become a nightmare, so
profoundly wrong that
he called it sinful.
And he hated the sin more than
any casual visitor or distant
critic possibly could.
Yet, he also saw here a dream of
redemption so unlikely and
glorious that it could only
fill the mind's eye of a
visionary native son.
Once driving through Cleveland
County, Dean happened to pass
the hard-shell Baptist church
that his father had once tried
to get, but failed, the failure
that had broken his
father's will.
Dean had gone down with his
father to Cleveland County and
heard the sermon that he'd given
for his audition back
around 1975, so that
decades later, he
recognized the church.
And he also noticed that there
was now a fucking Bojangles
right next door.
For Dean, Bojangles had come to
represent everything that
was wrong with the way Americans
lived-- how they
raise their food and transported
it across the
country, how they grew the crops
to feed the animals they
ate, the way they employed the
people who worked in the
restaurants, the way the money
left the community, everything
about it was wrong.
Dean's own business, gas
and fast food, had
become hateful to him.
And he saw the error of his ways
as his father never had.
And the conjunction of his
father's legacy and his own
struck him with bitter irony
as he drove past.
He was seeing beyond the
surfaces of the land to its
hidden truths.
Some nights, he sat up late on
his front porch with a glass
of Jack and listened to the
trucks heading south on 220,
carrying crates of live chickens
to the slaughter
houses always under cover of
darkness like a vast and
shameful trafficking, chickens
pumped full of hormones that
left them too big to walk.
And he thought how these same
chickens might return from
their destination as pieces of
meat to the floodlit Bojangles
up the hill from his house.
And that meat would be drowned
in the bubbling fryers by
employees whose hatred
of the job would leak
into the cooked food.
And that food would be served up
and eaten by customers who
would grow obese and end up in
the hospital in Greensboro
with diabetes or heart
failure, a
burden to the public.
And later Dean would see them
riding around the Mayodan
Walmart in electric carts
because they were too heavy to
walk the aisles of the
super-center, just like a
hormone-fed chickens.
So that's Dean Price's vision.
And it's a dark one.
But it contains these seeds of
renewal, which he is, as we
speak, out there pursuing
and selling every day.
And although there's a dark edge
to this vision of America
in my book, when I think about
Washington or Wall Street or
corporate America,
I get depressed.
But when I'm with someone like
Dean or Tammy Thomas or the
other characters, I feel more
hopeful because they have this
resilience and this
resourcefulness that I think
may not be uniquely American,
but that you find everywhere
in this country, in the most
out of the way places where
the media never goes and no
one's paying attention.
And I wanted to bring those
stories to light as well as to
describe the larger darkness
in which they're unfolding.
And that's what "The Unwinding"
is about.
And if you have any questions
on your lunch hour here, I
would be very happy
to hear them.
[APPLAUSE]
GEORGE PACKER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So--
GEORGE PACKER: Wait
for the mic.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
So I think you anticipated my
question with your closing.
But I'm just curious how
much of a tragic story
you think this is.
Because when I hear you describe
this, what really
comes across, the main threads,
would be class,
wealth, power, morality.
And I think back to the story my
grandmother told me growing
up in the Depression.
And frankly some of the tragedy
and some of the gross
injustice that we hear about
today pales in comparison to
those stories.
So I'm curious how you think
this compares to historical
precedence.
GEORGE PACKER: Right.
It's a good question.
I'm really glad to talk about
history because we don't talk
about it enough in
this country.
Americans were much
poorer then.
Life was harder.
There was no air conditioning.
Imagine being Dean Price in
North Carolina and having no
air conditioning, which
transformed the South.
The food may have been locally
produced, but there probably
wasn't enough of it, which is
a different problem from
eating at Bojangles.
Emaciation may have been more
the problem than obesity.
A lot of people didn't even
go to school, let
alone go to bad schools.
So no one should say this
is as bad as the worst.
What I feel is that we have
taken a big step back toward
that by undoing the structures
that were put in place in the
Depression and afterward, in
the postwar period, which
supported middle class
aspirations, which gave some
help and sort of channelled the
ambitions of ordinary people.
Those structures have begun
to fold, as I've
described in the book.
And although it's created this
tremendous opportunity and
freedom for people with the
ability, the talent, and the
luck to take advantage, it's
also left countless Americans
behind, which is something that
we can forget here in the
Bay Area, which is one of the
very few parts of the country
that has really done well over
the last generation.
So my feeling is we don't need
to look to the Great
Depression for comparisons.
I'm worried about the direction
we're going in.
And it seems to me that if
you've seen "The Great Gatsby"
or if you've, better yet, read
the novel, which I would
recommend over the movie any
day, we're getting closer to
that America where life is lived
through the people at
the top and through the
celebrities and their stories.
And ordinary people no longer
see themselves rising with the
top of society.
It's more like the top
has risen from
the rest of the country.
And the worship of celebrity is
one symptom of the failure
of institutions.
As I wrote in the prologue,
celebrities are taking the
place of institutions.
Tech billionaires are funding
school systems.
TV hostesses are floating
the publishing industry.
And I worry that when these
core institutions are
personalized that way and depend
so much on the private
whims and ideals of the most
successful, they're very
vulnerable.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
did you learn
anything from any of your
characters that you weren't
expecting to learn?
Or did you come in trying to
tell a narrative that you had
already had an opinion towards,
and then just pick
and choose from what they
told you to help you
tell you that narrative?
GEORGE PACKER: Right.
So I'll tell you a little
about my method.
It's the method of total
immersion, so that I would run
across someone like
Dean Price.
I'm working on another
"New Yorker" story.
And 30 seconds after hearing
him talk on the phone about
biodiesel, I knew that I needed
to get to know this guy
because he had both this passion
and articulateness,
but also admittedly kind of
a salesman's brilliance in
conveying his vision.
I went down to North Carolina,
lived in his house, maybe half
a dozen or eight times, met his
family, hung out with him,
traveled around the back woods
of North Carolina in his
beat-up Honda while he went from
county to county trying
to get local schools to buy
into the idea of using
biodiesel for school buses.
And there's no way I could have
had an opinion about any
of that before I went because
I didn't know any of it.
It was all discovery.
Admittedly, I was looking for
stories of Americans who were
in some way struggling both to
remake themselves and to come
up with a new vision of their
own part of the country.
I was interested in people who
are rooted in one place and
were still focused on that place
rather than had some
giant idea that applied
everywhere and nowhere.
And it wasn't always
easy to find them.
But once you do, you really
get out of the way because
they're so much more interesting
than whatever
preconceived ideas I or you
could have about them.
And the other point about the
method is there's no first
person anywhere in this book.
The word I coming from me does
not appear, which is a
complete departure from my
earlier work and was a really
important decision.
And I think it had the great
benefit of giving you the
feeling that you're
watching a movie.
And you don't want to be
distracted from that movie.
If I were to start saying
something about these
characters in my own voice, it
would be like the guy next to
you talking in the
middle the film.
You'd want to shut me up.
So there's more of a sense, I
think, of discovery and of the
characters and their language.
You can kind of hear in that
Dean Price passage, these are
not really my words
so much as his.
The word sinful is not a word I
would've used about Bojangles.
That's Dean Price.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You were mentioning
how the unwielding was sort of
setting us back to a time when
these icons were sort of
leading us.
And one of the things that
interested me in coming here
is just the fact that you work
at "The New Yorker." And I
find that sometimes "The New
Yorker" and a few other
publications are the ones that
present these sort of reality
news stories.
I was wondering, back in the
day when the icons were
leading, they were the
newspaper owners.
They were giving us--
or people who lived then--
the news.
So I was wondering, from your
perspective, how much of that
is happening today, again?
Is there a return to where the
wealthy, the icons, are
determining what information
is being delivered?
And even, I mean, maybe even
at "The New Yorker"--
I don't know.
GEORGE PACKER: I'd say two
things are happening at once.
It's a really good question.
On the one hand, there's this
tremendous diffusion of
information, which maybe your
company as much as any other
force in our society
is responsible for.
So that more people have more
access to more information
than at any time in
human history.
It's the most radical change in
how we think and interact
with information in,
maybe, ever.
And I think that is partly a
good thing because it has
given people who used to
not have any access
to it a lot of access.
Google is laying fiber optic
cable in towns around the
country that don't have it.
It has also done what
my book describes.
It has broken up and sort of
fragmented the idea that
there's a common world we live
in and a common set of facts.
When I had that long list of
what you're now free to do,
you're free to get
your own facts.
Everyone has their own facts
and their own websites and
Twitter feeds that reinforce
those facts.
And although that seems
empowering and liberating, it
also has a negative effect of
fracturing us so that there's
no place where we can all meet
and have an argument the way
"Time Magazine" and the "CBS
Evening News" used to kind of
command the belief of enough
people that there was a world
in which everyone agreed
they were living in.
Your question about money and
the news is really well taken.
I don't know if you've read that
David Koch of the Koch
brothers, the oil fortune, is
perhaps going to buy Times
Mirror Company--
the "LA Times," "Chicago
Tribune," and countless other
newspapers, radio stations,
TV stations.
Some of this was made possible
by a law, the 1996
Telecommunications Act, which
took the lid off how many news
outlets one company could own.
And that inevitably led
to consolidation.
So we have this Google-driven
dispersion and then this
concentrated wealth-driven
consolidation.
And I'm not sure, you know,
if there's going to
be a winner in that.
But I do think that there was
a period when corporations
owned news organizations but did
not use them in the same
way that David Koch will use the
"LA Times" if he gets it.
Fortunately, "The New Yorker,"
although it's owned by a
family, is owned by family that
doesn't seem to want to
tell "The New Yorker"
what to write.
And that's, I think, a good
thing, because I like what I
read in "The New Yorker." And
I want it to continue.
I want to continue
to have a job.
None of us can ever be sure
of that in this world.
But it's a very confused and
tumultuous period in the news.
And there's a reporter in my
book from the "St. Petersburg
Times" that kind
of represents--
he's just an old-fashioned shoe
leather reporter in the
age of Facebook and Twitter,
where his whole job may no
longer be necessary in the
eyes of his readers.
And he's still trying
to do what
reporters have always done.
AUDIENCE: So you seem to be
referring to this ethos that
held the country together
pre-1970s, which I think most
of us recognize as, you know,
that was often a Judeo
Christian, WASP-y, rather
bigoted ethos.
And when it's we've liberated
more and more groups to have
their voice heard or what have
you, I think, you know, some
would call that action itself a
tipping point, but that was
more indicative of, like, as you
got more freedoms, as we
all got more freedoms, we now
have greater responsibilities.
And there are more people
at the table.
And it's easier to be
anonymous when making decisions.
So do we need a return
to that ethos?
Do we need a new ethos?
And who gets to decide that?
I mean, how does this country
move towards cohesion again
after this massive fracturing?
GEORGE PACKER: That's
a great question.
I think what you're pointing
to is the fact that two
seemingly contradictory things
have been happening over the
course of the period
in the unwinding.
One, greater and greater social
equality, more and more
groups admitted into the circle
of opportunity, power,
a place near the top.
Oprah gave the Harvard
commencement
address last week.
Gay boys had just been allowed
to become Boy Scouts.
And no one would want to go
back to 1960 if that's
what we would get.
I would say that that period had
in its own structures the
tools of self-correction.
The civil rights period is
a great example of that.
Within the institutions of
Congress, the media, and
social movements, there was the
ability to correct this
gross historical injustice.
I don't know that we have the
tools to correct what's
happened alongside this widening
inclusiveness, which
is widening disparities.
More and more people can get to
the top, but more and more
people are never going to get
to the top because we are
becoming more stratified.
And where you're born is more
and more where you're going to
end up, which is to me, such a
threat to a basic conviction
of Americans and our democracy,
which is equal
opportunity.
I mean if there's a bedrock
value alongside freedom, it's
equality of opportunity.
I think anyone who looks at the
way the country is going
today has to admit that
is less and less real.
So who gets to decide
how we fix that?
I mean, you do.
We all do.
All I want to do was hold up a
mirror and say, read this and
get a feeling for what it's like
to be in America today,
and for the years that have kind
of proceeded this moment
and led to it.
And I'm not going to tell you,
here are the 10 policy
prescriptions.
You will not find an epilogue
that gives you, you know,
let's get rid of the carried
interest exemption for hedge
fund manager, although
I think we should.
It's not that kind of book.
I hope it reaches you on a
deeper level and tells you
more like, this is what it feels
like to be alive and in
America at this moment.
And maybe that can give readers
a more useful way of
thinking about your question,
who gets to decide and how do
we find some new cohesion than
another policy prescription
book would give you.
AUDIENCE: Do you think people
would have had a harder time
empathizing--
or not really empathizing,
but awareness, right?
Because you're trying to find
a bunch of different people
with very different backgrounds
in different
places in the country that are
in many ways very isolated
from each other, that maybe
would never run into each
other that are very different
experiences.
Do you think, in terms of
people's ability to even
comprehend that those worlds
exist in our country, do you
think that is lesser or greater
now than it would have
been in like the time period
you're pointing to, 25 years
ago [INAUDIBLE]?
GEORGE PACKER: I love
that question.
First of all, it makes
me think--
two weeks ago, Dean Price and
Tammy Thomas were both staying
in my house.
They actually met to
go to a party for
the book in New York.
And it was one of
the weirdest--
imagine the contents of my head
was staying in my house
and talking to each other.
It was really crazy
and really fun.
But your question is more
serious than that.
And I think it is harder for
Americans to know how other
Americans live than it used to
be, even though we have all
kinds of tools--
YouTube, et cetera--
just to see it from every
part of the country.
I found when I was researching
this book, going from Brooklyn
to Stokesdale, North Carolina
felt in some ways like a
longer trip than going from
Brooklyn to Rangoon, Burma,
which I did in 2008,
or Baghdad, even.
Partly because we are
in the same country.
We have these common
reference points.
And yet we're living such
different lives.
What we eat is different.
The way we talk is different.
The way we think--
not to say homogenization and
the suburbanization of life
after the war was such
a wonderful thing.
But you look back and kind of
feel a little nostalgic for an
America where everyone went
to public school.
And the quality of public
schools was actually not
wildly different unless you were
in a really, really poor
place or a really, really
rich place.
I went to high school in Palo
Alto in the '70s right before
Proposition 13 began the gutting
of the tax base for
education in California.
Everybody I knew went to public
school except the
screw-ups who got sent
to a private school.
Now, I know that private schools
have become a major
avenue for the new elite
of the Bay Area.
And I can't help feeling that
we're losing something.
That our lives-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: Not just
the Bay Area.
GEORGE PACKER: I know,
everywhere.
Everywhere.
I feel like here, the schools
were so good and were so
egalitarian in a way that, to
me, it's like a model that has
been lost right here in our
own neck of the woods.
But I do think we're divided
and separate in so many
different ways.
And it's just a shock when
you leave one of the more
successful parts of the country
to one of the less.
AUDIENCE: Two things.
First, that I think the collapse
of the textile
industry is one of the
untold stories.
My wife is from Cleveland
County, North Carolina.
And so thank you for
telling that.
GEORGE PACKER: It's a big part
of Dean Price's life, because
that was the job that was
waiting for you out of high
school, right?
AUDIENCE: And all those plants
are just, you know, they're
empty, closed.
I mean, you've been
there and seen it.
But I was wondering, as you're
riding around with Dean Price
or other people, you know,s and
he's talking to people, do
any of them say, who's this
guy and what's he doing?
What are you doing?
What are you doing
with that pad?
GEORGE PACKER: Hell, yes.
Hell, yes.
AUDIENCE: What are you doing
with that tape recorder?
GEORGE PACKER: I had to
explain it every time.
Fortunately, most people,
especially in small towns and
rural America, are less
suspicious of journalists than
the White House, Facebook,
and Goldman Sachs.
So rather than having to set a
whole bunch of ground rules
and then run quotes by them for
their approval, which is
what reporters routinely do
now-- and it's actually quite
a corrupt system where the
source gets to rewrite the
quote as per the original ground
rules, but that's like
the power that institutions
we want to cover have--
if you're a decent person and
are truly interested--
not just pretending, because
they'll pick that up-- if
you're truly interested and
have some empathy, I have
always found whether it's in
Surry County, North Carolina
or Kirkuk, Iraq, people want
to tell their story.
And it's only when they're in
a sort of quasi official
position that they get nervous
that it's going to come back
to bite them.
Most of the people Dean was
talking to were, like, tobacco
farmers, former textile
or furniture workers.
They were OK with it.
And so far, I haven't heard
anyone telling me that I
destroyed their life.
And I hope I haven't.
AUDIENCE: So clearly you wrote
the book from a very
US-centric--
you're telling a story about
the United States.
But I'm curious if there were
any problems or themes that
you think could be applied at
a more global scale, like
things you've seen in your
travels or solutions that you
thought might be applied
globally?
GEORGE PACKER: You know, you're
getting at perhaps a
weakness in the book, which is
it is so much about the US and
my literary model was John Dos
Passos trilogy "U.S.A.," which
is about the first decades
of the 20th century,
a trilogy of novels.
That the Iraq War has a little
place in my book, but I'd
already written a book
about the Iraq War.
Do I need to do that again?
Iran Contra is mentioned.
It's like you're seeing the
world and the big events of
history out of your peripheral
vision while you're living
through the lives of
these characters.
And I guess I'd say I learned
how insular Americans are.
My characters were not talking
about the wars very much.
They weren't talking
about globalization
and India and China.
They were talking about what
was happening in their
neighborhood.
And that, it may be a human
trait, b but I think it's also
an American trait.
We're so big and surrounded
by oceans.
And there's so much
going on here.
And we're so obsessed with
ourselves that honestly the
rest of the world kind of
disappeared during these
conversations I had.
And so, in being true to
the point of view of my
characters, I let the world
sort of slip away.
I think the best point of
comparison is Europe where
there have been unwindings
across the continent,
especially since the
financial crisis.
But where a country like Germany
has somehow decided to
hold on to certain institutional
constraints that
keep society from completely
fracturing.
So that after the financial
crisis and the recession, they
had these job-share plans where
people worked fewer
days, but more people
got to work.
And that was a decision the
German government made in
order to make sure unemployment
didn't get out of control.
That's just one of many policy
decisions that tell you
globalization is not the only
cause of these things.
There are also decisions made
by governments and by
businesses that drive the forces
that are causing this
falling apart.
And Germany's a very good
counter example to the path
that we've taken.
But it's not in the book.
The book is very much, as you
can see, about our country.
One more question here?
AUDIENCE: You talked a bit
about Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs benefiting
from this.
Can you talk a bit about how
you feel, if any, Silicon
Valley has contributed to
the unwinding at all?
GEORGE PACKER: That's
a great question.
You might have heard that I
wrote an article in "The New
Yorker" a couple weeks ago
that's kind of about how
Silicon Valley is getting more
involved in politics and
what's driving that.
My feeling about Silicon Valley
is it's good, but it's
not enough.
It's done great things for
a lot of individuals.
But in the grand scheme of
things, the employment level
is so small compared
to General Motors.
Twitter, which dominates my
world of media, has-- what--
like 900 employees here
in San Francisco.
Google is far bigger, and not to
curry any favor here, but I
think Google may be the one of
the new tech companies that
sort of is looking more
like the economy
that has been replaced.
I don't think social
networking--
I'm a skeptic.
I don't think it's going
to drive middle-class
standard of living up.
I think what it does is gives us
lots and lots of wonderful
tools and massive distraction,
even addiction.
I know that for my own life,
this thing owns me.
And it may be that it--
I walk around the streets here
and everyone is staring at
their phone.
It's kind of like a picture of
the unwinding, like no one is
talking to each other, no one
is looking at each other.
I think virtual technology has
sort of created conditions
where we are more divided from
each other in life and maybe
were connected in all kinds
of ways, as well.
Peter Thiel is in my book
because he's one big figure
out here, a libertarian,
not my politics at all.
But he's a critic of
the boosterism of
the Information Age.
He says it just hasn't
raised living
standards across the country.
In fact, it's coincided with
the hollowing out of the
middle class.
It's a very hard thing
to explain.
How is it that this revolution
that has changed life in the
way Americans and people around
the world live has not
changed or improved the fortunes
of the broad middle
class in America the way
the Automobile Age did?
And that's something--
I don't have an answer, but it
may be something that you all
will want to think about and
talk to each other about.
Because to me, it's very much a
question for Silicon Valley.
Thanks so much for coming.
I appreciate you taking
the time.
[APPLAUSE]